thank you I'm so happy to be here
tonight as the Governor's Award goes to
my friend great cinematographer Owen
royzman he will leave here tonight with
the Oscar he's so long deserved in 1971
when I was just out of college and
desperate to direct movies the French
Connection exploded into the world it
combined all the grit and grime and
handheld excitement of documentary
filmmaking with the narrative drive of
the best Hollywood thriller the genius
of that brew changed movies forever a
few there a few years later Owen and
Billy Friedkin collaborated again
working under very different conditions
they created a movie that scared the
pants off of everybody in the world The
Exorcist was shot on elaborate sets with
hundreds of in-camera effects along with
startling expressionistic confrontations
of darkness and light and yet people
sometimes forget the reality level of
the story is amplified by the hyper
realistic shots of Georgetown and
Washington that frame the harm
oh and Cha westerns and thrillers and
comedies sometimes he showed more than
one at the same time I'll give you an
example if you watch Network you see the
perfect marriage of theme and image
there's a great scene where the head of
the network Ned Beatty reads the bride
Act two anchorman Peter Finch in a long
conference room lit only by the lamps on
the table there's really been a stronger
evocation of God's wrath raining down on
a mere mortal with Sydney [ __ ] oh and
made Tootsie one of the funniest movies
of all times
it was chock-full of beautiful faces
sophisticated compositions and startling
reservoirs of emotion the remarkable
achievements kept coming three days of
the Condor straight time the electric
horseman true confessions taps absence
of malice we all wanted our movies to
look like that but Owen was something
doing something more than just
redefining the look of Hollywood films
he was inspiring young cinematographers
and filmmakers all over the world you
can see his influence in hundreds of
movies made since the French Connection
the private Owen royzman is funny and
generous and impossibly sweet Owen and I
made four movies together he was
nominated for wider when we were out
scouting those locations we would be
dazzled we were both not young men but
what we saw made us feel all the
excitement of young men when you get to
place figures in that magnificent
landscape to tell a big story about
America you know you've had a lucky life
Owen has inspired young filmmakers for
40 years he will inspire them forever
he is the great Owen Reisman
[Applause]